[موسيقى]
لقد انتقلت من القاهرة عبر
نهر النيل إلى موقع قديم يعرف باسم
وادي الملوك ومدينة
الأقصر
[موسيقى]
أين الكلاب المجنونة
إنه نفس سؤال الأهرامات
كيف فعلوا ذلك  لقد حان
الوقت لإنشاء معبد هوت تشيب السخام
المخصص لإحدى الفراعنة المشهورات في مصر.
روعة هذا المكان
لا يمكننا حقًا أن نفكر
في الكلمات التي قد يأتي بها المرء
لوصف جماله
المثير للإعجاب حقًا كما هي هذه الهياكل بوضوح.
دعونا نتذكر السبب وراء
بناء الكثير منها في المقام الأول،
فهي مقابر ومقابر مصممة لتسهيل حياة
الحكام في حياتهم الآخرة،
نحن ملوكنا وهذا هو المكان الذي
دفن فيه جميع الفراعنة المشهورين،
لماذا دفنوا جميعًا هنا جيدًا؟
انظر هذا يبدو وكأنه هرم هنا،
نعم، لذلك انتقلوا من بناء الهرم
إلى مكان مختبئ بعيدًا، يريدون أن يختبأوا
عن النيل حتى يتمكنوا من العيش إلى
الأبد ولا يتم العثور عليهم،
الصحفية السابقة التي تحولت إلى مؤلفة
بيتسي هيل هي مرشدتي في الأقصر،
فكيف  المهم هل كان يجب أن تكون
مدفونًا هنا، كنت الحاكم،
كنت الفرعون وكنت
حاكم مصر، هذه
القوة الإقليمية العظيمة ولهذا السبب أراد كل هؤلاء
الأشخاص أن يُدفنوا هنا،
وهذا هو الروعة الحقيقية
تحت الأرض
المدينة الأولى كانت واحدة من
بداية الأسرة التاسعة عشرة منذ حوالي
3200 عام، ومقبرته هي واحدة من
أعمق المقبرة يبلغ طولها حوالي 400 قدم، لذا
يعتقد الناس أن هذا كان نفقًا سريًا
ربما كان يحتوي على كنز، وما زال
هذا هو ما أحبه  الأمر برمته
لأنه بغض النظر عن مقدار ما نعرفه، هناك
شخص يقول آه، أنت لا
تعرف كل هذا، أنت لا تعرف أنه هناك بالأسفل
أريد الذهاب إلى هناك وأريد
العثور على هذا الكنز، هل تعتقد أنه لا
يزال هناك بعض  هناك
لا تعرف أبدًا
وبهذه النغمة المبهجة نبدأ النزول
[موسيقى]
هنا ترى هذا هو التابوت
الذي كان سيحتوي على سيتي وهو يتجه
إلى العالم السفلي لذلك سيكون هذا
جزءًا من رحلته وعلى طول الطريق لديه
حليف حليف  وأولئك الذين يقاتلون ضده في
رحلته حذرين ومثيرين بعض الشيء،
لا يسعني إلا أن أشعر وكأنني إنديانا جونز
وما هو القبر القديم إذا لم يكن به
فخ مفخخ مناسب لذلك كان هذا
فخًا، نعم كانوا يحاولون ذلك  أبقِ
لصوص المقابر خارجًا، وكما ترون، فهو
لا يريد أن يسقط هناك
ويسمع ثباتًا مع أوزوريس
طوال السنوات، وهو جالس هنا كلبًا
تمامًا، كلما
تعمقنا أكثر،
أصبحت هذه المقبرة أكثر روعة وتفصيلًا،
أوه، هذا هو الدفن الرائع، لذا
أنت قادم
بنظرة جميلة متصاعدة هنا، نظرة الكاهن
إلى حزام الفهد،
كل ذلك من نوع ثلاثي الأبعاد،
تفاصيل رائعة ونقش بارز،
أين كان الملك
سيكون الملك هنا،
هذه هي غرفة الدفن
وهي رائعة  أوه
أتجول على اليمين
[موسيقى]